Hey, Jill.
Hi, Sean.
We really enjoyed meeting with you.
The salary you're asking for, it's a little higher than average.
What experience and skills do you feel support that?
I've been leading one of the fastest-growing open-source projects...
...and some of our contributors are developers for some of the biggest tech companies.
So, I've been able to see how industry leaders operate.
That's impressive.
I feel you'd be a great addition to our team.
We're willing to meet you in the middle and offer 95,000.
I appreciate the offer.
I could take on this role for that amount,...
...assuming the package includes a signing bonus and two additional weeks of vacation.
I think we can make that happen.
I'll send you the details.